so Alex Jones and Infowars have been
banned from Facebook YouTube iTunes also
Spotify I think some other platforms as
well I've gotten an get gotten in on the
action and this all happened at once
this was this was within 12 hours the
three big gatekeepers of the internet
Facebook Google Apple all decided to
shut down Alex Jones and there's just no
way that that's a coincidence there's no
way that they all got up independently
on Monday morning and said you know what
I'm gonna I think we're gonna ban Alex
Jones today yeah that's what we're gonna
do know that this very this very much
seems to be a conspiracy between the
three big tech giants to censor Alex
Jones and listen it doesn't matter how
you personally feel about Alex Jones
that should not have any bearing on the
way you look at this story
because hate him or love him there's a
precedent being set here
that should concern everybody especially
conservatives and you might say Alex
Jones isn't a conservative he's a
conspiracy if there is yada yada doesn't
matter that discussion doesn't matter
because you know what in the minds of
Facebook Apple Google we're all the same
you may draw a distinction between
conservatives and Alex Jones they don't
draw that distinction
in their minds we're all in the same
boat and there's you know I I don't
think that at this point we can say that
this is a First Amendment issue at least
not yet these are private companies and
I have always affirmed the rights of
private companies to do business the way
they want to do business with whoever
they want that that's that's up to them
to freedom of association and I don't
buy the argument that Facebook is a
monopoly and so therefore this is a
First Amendment issue Facebook is not a
monopoly there are a million other
social media platforms out there and we
could just as easily
this isn't like this isn't like it's
1857 and somebody's got a monopoly on
the railroads okay and so if you want to
use a railroads you've got no option
that's not the case here there are a
million social media platforms that we
could just as easily use any of them we
choose to go to Facebook we could choose
to go somewhere else and it would
require no effort it's just a matter of
clicking on a different app so it's like
instead of doing this we do that that's
that's the amount of effort required to
use a different social media platform
and if we decide that that is too much
like to bring our finger down here to
the different app on our phone if that's
just too much that's too much effort
well that's that's kind of on us so it's
not monopoly Facebook has two billion
users I think because they all choose to
use Facebook instead of something else
and so then Facebook can do what they
want with their own platform that we
have all chosen to use now that said
there is
this could easily develop into a very
serious First Amendment issue and so
let's look at Senator Chris Murphy from
Connecticut sent out a tweet yesterday
in relation to this story and this is
what he said he said info were Infowars
is the tip of a giant iceberg of hate
and lies that uses sites like Facebook
and YouTube to tear our nation apart
these companies must do more than take
down one website the survival of our
democracy depends on it so if you happen
to be a constituent of Senator Chris
Murphy you may want to keep in mind come
election time that he thinks the
survival of our democracy depends on the
restriction of free speech maybe you
agree with it maybe you're anti-american
as well but if you're not you may want
to keep that in mind
I don't see how any decent American
could vote for a senator who would say
something like that because that now
this is First Amendment what he's saying
this is a government official saying
companies must do more
to restrict speech that I don't
personally like
and if he decided to officially get
involved if the Democrats officially got
involved you got to shut down this
speech which we could very much which we
would certainly be heading in that
direction well then it is a straight up
war on the First Amendment but either
way even if what's happening now is
legal that doesn't mean it's defensible
doesn't mean that it's right
doesn't mean that it isn't dangerous it
is possible to do something legal yet
bad that happens all the time in this
country and I think this is one of those
times now the justification for this the
basis that was provided is is is
something we should be really concerned
because all of these companies have
claimed in unison that this is part of a
crackdown on hate speech okay
hate speech now let's think about hate
speech for a minute because when the
when the real war on the First Amendment
begins it will begin on this basis of we
have to go after hate speech and I think
there are gonna be a lot of frankly very
stupid Americans who will say well I
mean that's okay as long if it's hateful
speech I mean how can I how could I have
any problem with that if it's we of
course we got to get rid of hate speech
we have to get rid of all the hate
speech and leave only good speech I mean
you know that's what the First Amendment
meant to protect is good speech not hate
speech well hate speech is a nonsensical
ambiguous phrase by design
ambiguous because the people who use it
want to be able to apply it to whatever
right so it's a lot like a hate crime in
that case in fact let's step to the side
for a minute because I think it helps us
to understand hate speech let's let's
start but let's let's think about hate
crime okay first of all the whole
problem with a hate crime with with the
category of hate crime is that any crime
could be motivated by hate it doesn't
make any sense to say well we have this
special category of crime of that's
motivated by hate that any almost any
crime that's ever been committed in the
history of mankind could have had some
hatred involved in it right or maybe not
and you can't really know whether there
was hatred behind the crime or not
because hatred isn't um it's an emotion
it's a passion it's a feeling how can
you prove what emotions went into a
crime and more importantly why does it
matter what difference does it make if I
were look if I were to key your car or
slash your tires because I hate you or
because I hate the demographic that you
belong to and then I work and then I'm
on like I'm on a crime spree here so
then I go to your neighbor's house and I
kill him because I want to steal his TV
I'm sure that you would you would agree
that you got the better end of the
bargain even though you were the victim
of the hate crime my crime against you
was motivated by hate my crime against
your neighbor was motivated by greed but
in that case the greed crime is worse so
there are motivations that can lead us
to do worse things if anything even take
two crimes that are the same let's let's
take two murders okay let's say I kill
you because I hate you and then let's
say I kill your neighbor because I want
to steal his TV well I would say
even then the crime against you is bad
and I should go to jail for it obviously
but it's actually slightly less bad it's
it's it's it's evil it's not even it's
not quite as evil as my crime against
your neighbor I would say because you I
was angry I hate you I kill you
terrible I should go to jail forever but
your neighbor I just was totally
indifferent to his life and I just I
wanted his TV and his life meant nothing
to me total indifference and in that
case you know when you kill somebody
because of total indifference and so
you're willing to kill them over their
shoes or the TV I think that makes you a
bigger threat to society that makes you
a more dangerous person and the
possibility of reforming a person like
that is probably less likely than
reforming someone who commits a quote
hate crime so treating hate crime as the
worst possible thing is is it just
doesn't make sense I think a similar
thing is the case with hate speech hate
speech is not in objected category of
speech hatred is a motivation it is a
it's a feeling it's a passion that can
motivate speech but you can't prove it
Kait speech when you say hate speech
that is an accusation you're accusing
somebody it's an assertion and
accusation it is not in itself a proof
when you call something hate speech you
are inferring based on your own
subjective analysis that hatred was the
motivation behind the speech when you
say let's ban hate speech what you mean
is let's ban speech that in my opinion
nobody could possibly Express unless
they're hateful but that's obviously
arbitrary and subjective and impossible
to prove and when you try to enforce
something like that it is
going to be enforced on a partisan
uneven basis there's no way around it
and we know that the left has already
already determined that nobody could
ever for instance critique
transgenderism or gay marriage or
abortion or feminism or socialism or
affirmative action etc etc etc unless
they're hateful so just like that all
non liberal speech is hate speech but
the problem is when you call something
hate speech especially if you're using
that phrase to describe a political
opinion that somebody expressed well all
you're really revealing is that you
don't understand you you can't
sympathize with that point of view I
think most of the time when someone says
that's hate speech what they're really
saying is I can't sympathize with that
because they don't understand a using
the gay marriage example leftist belief
that any opposition to gay marriage is
hateful it's all hate speech because
they just can't wrap their head around
they cannot sympathize with the opinion
that gay marriage is not a legitimate
form of marriage they can't sympathize
with that opinion however those of us
who hold that opinion we know that it's
got nothing to do with hate we don't
have any hate in our hearts about it
this is just a matter of of observing
and defining what marriage inherently is
you can disagree you could say that that
that opinion is wrong but you don't get
to sit there and declare that's hateful
there is hate in your heart you're not
the one who gets to decide that I can
tell you what's going on inside my heart
and you have no choice but to believe me
because I am the only authority on earth
when it comes to what's happening inside
my heart and what motivations are behind
the things that I say and do I am the
only authority on
this planet and so you have to listen to
me and you have to believe me it's the
only way this works so just because you
can't sympathize with a point of view
does not make it hateful it may be wrong
it may be many things but that not
necessarily hateful I mean I don't
understand let's take a point up an
opinion or a point of view that I can't
sympathize with I cannot sympathize with
the opinion that Marvel movies are good
I don't understand why people love
Marvel movies so much I think that
they're stupid and pointless and I just
wish they would stop already I don't get
it and it feels to me like there's some
kind of conspiracy to annoy me and
that's why they keep coming out with
these stupid movies it feels hey
honestly it feels hateful it feels like
hate when somebody says oh I can't wait
for the new Avengers movie to me it
feels like hate speech it's hate because
I it's it's just it makes me annoyed and
and angry when I hear that it feels like
hate speech but I can't prove that I
can't prove that your opinion that you
like that the Marvel movies are good I
can't prove that that opinion is based
on a hatred for me it's possible that it
is and it's possible that that's just
your opinion and you're expressing it I
don't know but this is how hate speech
works when someone calls something hate
speech it is simply a statement about
how they the listener feel about this
opinion so it reminds me of it reminds
me of of that scene in the office when
somebody defecates on Michaels carpet
and then he called he says it's hate
speech and then Stanley says it's not
hate speech and Michael goes well I
hated it
and that's that's essentially how this
works
of course there there are exceptions
right I mean there are things that
people say that are clear clearly
hateful like if I say I hate you well
then I think it's safe to assume that
there's hatred behind what I just said
or any time you say something abusive
insulting to another person
there's very likely to be hatred behind
it but the problem first of all is that
that describes like 85% of the speech on
on the internet and so if Facebook was
really gonna shut down hate speech they
would have to shut down almost every
profile on the on their site but often
that exactly the kind of speech that is
not called hate speech or if it is
called hate speech
it's called hate speech very selectively
PII people insult me on the Internet
literally hundreds of times a day if I
were to actually read all my comments
which I don't and read all my emails and
messages which I don't but if I were I
would I would be insulted hundreds of
times a day you if you don't believe me
just go look at the comments under
anything I ever write or do or any any
content of mine that I post there's
gonna be plenty of comments that are
just ripping and ripping me to shreds
right and to me that that seems hateful
right I just but but if I were to call
that hate speech and complain to
Facebook or Google about it or whatever
I I'm being victimized by hate speech if
I were to do that I would be told that
now that's not really hate speech
really this guy just told me to kill
myself that's not hate speech
you're not gonna ban him how is that not
if that's not hate speech but then I
don't know what hate speech me it means
and that's the point that often times
the most clearly hateful things are not
considered hate speech because hate
speech is just a broad ambiguous term
that it's it's just a vessel for
controlling speech that's all it is and
you know what even in cases where hate
is clearly the motivation behind the
speech even in cases where you have
clear-cut cut-and-dry hate speech okay
is that really the worst kind of speech
even in that case is it is hate speech
really the worst kind of speech that you
can find on the internet or anywhere in
life I don't think it is I mean what
about dishonest speech what about
manipulative speech what about
propaganda what about what about the
speech of somebody in the outraged mob
who isn't really hateful isn't really
angry but it's just kind of indifferent
and emotionally dead and is just saying
what they're saying in order to in order
to in order to whip up hysteria for fun
well yeah what about emotionally dead
speech let's call what about that I
would say that all those forms of speech
are are more dangerous than hate speech
much of the time so just as a hate crime
is not necessarily the worst kind of
crime and it's not the worst motivation
for a crime although it's bad it's not
the worst I think the same thing is the
case with hate speech and I would say in
general you know I think we have in our
culture a very off-balance focus on
hatred we act like hatred is the biggest
problem in our culture it's the worst
thing is hatred but I don't think that's
the case hatred is bad but I don't even
think that everyone's always so worried
about hatred is that you know the
disease that's infecting our culture I
don't think that's the case I think the
worst thing in our culture is and I made
this point before the worst thing is not
hatred the worst thing is is
indifference is just this kind of moral
indifference and that explains a lot of
what you see online our people you know
they don't really hate each other they
just don't recognize the humanity of
other people and they don't care and
they're kind of morally dead to the
world that's the worst thing
hatred isn't even half as bad as that
and that's the thing that is going to
propel people to do the worst sorts of
things as I've said in the past most of
these school shooters mass killers
serial killers and so on most of them
they're not hateful they they don't they
don't feel anything inside they have
nothing going on inside they're totally
empty and that's why they're doing what
they're doing it's just they're trying
to feel something they're just doing it
for entertainment because they have no
because they just don't recognize
humanity anymore so those are some
things to keep in mind about about the
about the dreaded hate speech and it's
important to keep this in mind because
when the crackdown on the First
Amendment really begins and maybe we're
seeing it and it's just a tional phase
right now but when it really gets kicks
in a full gear it's gonna be under the
guise of cracking down on hate speech
thanks for watching everybody
god speed